congratulations on this phenomenal
movie you know
the first thing that i noticed is i
think it's fitting
that with the eternals having lived
among humanity for thousands and
thousands of years but the makeup of the
cast really represents a wide range of
humanity you've got this
whole diverse cast now how does it feel
for you guys to be leading these four
um with this foot forward with with
showing the breadth and beauty of
more of humanity
that's exactly right because they they
have been living amongst um humanity for
so long it just to me it feels very
natural um
that the cast looks like it does uh
we're all very different but it feels
like we've also been cast because
there are elements of our characters
within each of us so
i know i'm excited i'm excited for the
fact that there are probably a lot of
young boys and girls who are maybe going
to see themselves represented in a film
like this for the first time that feels
there's so many things about this film
that just look
phenomenal and i know that the audience
has gotten used to seeing effects that
look so real and it's hard to tell
between one thing and the other
sometimes but when it comes to certain
things that you were doing like say
richard you know icarus flying or
different fight scenes like
what are we seeing that's actually you
and what are we seeing that's
you know
well most of us me i mean that's the
kind of uh the the
the the pain and joy of not wearing a
mask as a superhero as it's got your
face doing it because if i had a mask on
we could have a stunt guy doing it or
you can cgi that easier but it's my face
so you're like okay let's put the
harness on let's get me up on the wires
and let's do some flying for
weeks and and luckily i've got gemma on
set with me every day to to say does
this look stupid do i look dumb um well
that's kind of my my main test was if
gemma signed it off i was like okay
we're doing it right
right nf gentleman was like i don't know
and he was plenty of times i mean you to
have you've got to have a friend who's
able to be honest with you like that you
know richard you look like peter pan you
need to change my position i'd be like
okay thank you i will change that
japan i love that
uh the eternals are pretty much like
eternal it's in the name they're eternal
they're kind of immortal in a way
so there's
a whole future of storytelling
possibilities out there for you guys um
gemma even
even knowing what you know about making
this film
do you know of any exciting
opportunities for the eternals moving
forward or anything you can imagine that
you'd want to do
josh well you're right you know
anything's possible um we have no idea
what the plans are you'd have to
get inside kevin feige's head
for that but you know i know in the
comics that cersei i think she becomes
an avenger so that would be fun
um
i don't know it would be fun for the
eternals to to to meet the guardians
i i'd be interested in that
no some people would say some game of
thrones fans would say that you were
probably in their dream love triangle in
this film
yeah i'm sure
someone's got to do it
it's the hard work that you are willing
to put in i know the fans i appreciate
that about you yeah
well thank you so much both you and
congratulations again on this film all
the best
you